sind wir wieder die dumm das finde ich
gar nicht gut dafür zahlen wir ja ich
möchte schon dass die Post pünktlich
kommt also morgen hatte lang kam die
Post sieben Tage nicht fünf Tage nicht
drei Tage nicht ich habe sogar
persönlich beim Schalter abgegeben und
er ist nicht angekommen in Berlin da
geht zwar vielleicht die Post ab aber
sie kommt immer häufiger immer später
oder gar nicht an immer mehr Menschen
klagen wo bleibt meine Post noch nie gab
es so viele Beschwerden über die
Deutsche Post und das obwohl sie weniger
Briefe befördert denn je und der Druck
wächst weiter dabei sind viele
postbotenen und boten schon jetzt am
Limit heute werden wir behandelt wie der
letzte Dreck ich habe noch 14 Jahre bis
zur Rente aber ich weiß wirklich nicht
ob ich das durchhalte doch was steckt
eigentlich dahinter woher kommen die
Probleme bei der Deutschen Post dazu
unser heutiger konntest
die postkundinnen und Kunden stören vor
allem drei zentrale Probleme erstens
Briefe kommen viel zu spät oder gar
nicht an Briefe die nicht ankommen sind
immer unangenehm für den Verkäufer und
für den Käufer an jedem Werktag stellt
die Post im Schnitt ca 59 Millionen
Briefe zu fakt ist aber das ist
zunehmend reine Theorie bei der
Bundesnetzagentur sind bis Ende Oktober
schon über 30.000 Beschwerden über die
Post eingegangen so viele wie noch nie
kommen wir zum zweiten Problem die
steigenden Preise wie zufrieden sind Sie
mit dem Angebot der Deutschen Post ja
eigentlich zu teuer ich finde es alles
zu teuer von der Sache her zwischen 2003
und 2012 kostet der ein Standardbrief 55
Cent ab 2016 bis 2018 waren es dann
schon 70 Cent und seit Januar 2022 ist
das Briefporto auf 85 Cent geklettert
das dritte Problem der schlechte Service
von von Zweigstellen zu machen wollen
dann weiß ich nicht wie das in Zukunft
werden soll Kunden und Kundinnen in
ländlichen Gegnern fühlen sich oft
abgehängt viele Menschen haben weite
Wege zu Briefkästen gleichzeitig gibt es
wenige Filialen die Folge die Post ist
so profitabel wie nie und zugleich
beschweren sich immer mehr Menschen über
sie wie kann das sein das schauen wir
uns an um die heutige Lage der Post zu
verstehen müssen wir einen Blick auf
ihre Geschichte werfen als
staatseigendes Unternehmen war die
Deutsche Bundespost Anfang der 80er
Jahre der größte Arbeitgeber der
Republik die über eine halbe Million
Beschäftigten waren damals nicht nur für
das Briefgeschäft zuständig in
Delmenhorst bei Bremen hat die Post den
26 eine millionsten Telefonanschluss in
der Bundesrepublik gelegt den neuen
fernsprechtsteilnehmern
Polizeiobermeister Klaus resto und
seiner Frau überreichte
bundespostminister christian Schwarz
Schilling CDU zum Jubiläum ein
komforttelefon mit gebührenanzeiger und
nummernspeichern
wird derzeit gegraben das Kabel kommt
Ziel des Bundesministers 80% der
Haushalte sollen mit Kabelanschluss
versorgt werden davon allerdings ist man
noch weit entfernt im Jahr darauf
verabschiedete die Bundesregierung die
erste Postreform mit dem Ziel der
Privatisierung um die Bundespost darauf
vorzubereiten wurde sie zunächst neu
strukturiert die Post geht ab genauer
gesagt der Gesetzentwurf zur Neuordnung
der Bundespost ist auf dem Weg in den
Bundesrat
diese Neuordnung bedeutet die Aufteilung
der Bundespost in drei Bereiche es
entstanden Postdienst Telekom und
Postbank die Post Angestellten
befürchteten Preissteigerung und
Arbeitsplatzverlust
die Beschäftigten der Bundespost haben
heute viele Orts gegen das neue
Organisationskonzept protestiert die
Gewerkschaft hält die Aufteilung der
Post in die Bereiche Brief und
Paketdienst Telekommunikation und
postbank-
schon damals im Zuge der
Wiedervereinigung mit Übernahme der
ostpost hatte die Post zunehmend den Ruf
unzuverlässig zu sein vor allem in der
Weihnachtszeit
nahezu verdoppelt hat sich seit der
deutschen Einheit die Flut von Paketen
Päckchen und Briefen die hier in
Magdeburger Hauptpostamt täglich
eintreffen
hinzu kommen jetzt die zahlreichen
Weihnachtsbriefe die auch die Postämter
in den alten Bundesländern vor Probleme
stellen ja Weihnachten rückt eben näher
und noch nie hatten die Bediensteten der
Bundespost einen solchen Bammel vor dem
Fest wie diesmal um die Privatisierung
zu vollenden folgte auf die erste
Postreform die zweite und zwar
ist uns versprochen worden dass
sozial verträglich gehandelt wird und
keine Leute entlassen werden jetzt will
man den Verträgen nicht zustimmen und
darum stehen wir hier der Unmut des
Personals hielt aber an als im Zuge
dessen 1995 die Deutsche Post AG
entstand eine Aktiengesellschaft in
staatlichen Besitz durch die
Privatisierung sollte Kapital
mobilisiert und der Wettbewerb gefördert
wird für die Mitarbeitenden hieß das
jedoch vor allem eins die erneute Sorge
um den Arbeitsplatz
bis 2006 trennte sich das Unternehmen
von der Mehrheit seiner Beamtin und
Beamten von ehemals einer halben Million
Beschäftigten der Deutschen Bundespost
ist die Post heute runter auf nur noch
150.000 Mitarbeiten in Deutschland nach
der Privatisierung wurden Vollzeit durch
teilzeitverträge ersetzt und zunehmend
Leiharbeiter und Leiharbeiterinnen und
Saisonkräfte eingestellt es blieb
natürlich nicht ohne Folgen für die
Arbeitsbedingungen
halt Fernsehen wie sie jetzt da sind
glänzen wir immer aber wenn dann halt
sie weg sind muss man leider so sagen
wir haben viele Leute weggehen meine
Schulter und meinen Rücken machen mir zu
schaffen ich habe schon zwei Operationen
hinter mir viele Kollegen bei uns haben
gesundheitliche Probleme Aufregungen hat
heute ein Papier der Deutschen Post
ausgelöst ist zeigt wie der Konzern mit
befristet angestellten Mitarbeitern
umgeht wer zu häufig wegen Krankheit
fehlt oder zu langsam ist bekommt keine
Festanstellung seit Jahren beschweren
sich mitarbeiten der übersteigenden
Druck und ein zu hohes arbeitspense ein
Grund warum Briefe nicht ankommt es
fehlt dann Personal vor allem bei der
Post zustelle mit der corona-pandemie
schwitzte sich die Situation zu die
Fachgewerkschaft der Post kritisiert die
Deutsche Post hat auf der einen Seite
exorbitante Gewinne sie investiert aber
zu wenig in Personal die Mitarbeiter
fühlen sich zum Teil als Masch kommen
wir nun zu den steigenden briefpreisen
sie hängen vor allem mit der
Monopolstellung der Deutschen Post
zusammen zwar wurde die Post ab 1995
privatisiert doch das Grundgesetz
sicherte der Deutschen Post AG
übergangsweise bestimmte Monopolrechte
zu um die flächendeckende Versorgung mit
Postdienstleistungen sicherzustellen mit
der quasi Monopolstellung der Deutschen
Post gingen Privilegien einher die sie
in nahezu konkurrenzlos bleiben ließ 56
Cent kostet es einen ganz normalen Brief
zu verschicken und der einzige Anbieter
für diesen Service ist die Deutsche Post
mit dem Brief Monopol macht sie die
satten Gewinne hier hat sie keine
Konkurrenz und den Leuten tut diese
kleine Summe kaum mehr auch aufgrund
dieser satten Gewinne sperrte sich die
Bundesrepublik lange gegen eine
wirksamere Wettbewerbskontrolle der Post
denn noch bis 2013 gehörten dem Bund
über die Staatsbank KfW über 25 Prozent
der postaktien es kann nicht sein dass
hier einer im Wettbewerb Mehrwertsteuer
Privileg hat und die anderen gucken in
die Röhre wir werden dieses Problem
gemeinsam zu regeln haben das
Briefmonopol fiel zwar offiziell im Jahr
2008 doch auch heute noch gehört die
Deutsche Post über die KfW Bank zur rund
20% dem Bund der auf diese Weise von
jeder Porto Erhöhung profitiert solange
die Post weitestgehend konkurrenzlos ist
können Sie die Preise weiter erhöhen
ohne ernsthafte Konsequenzen zu
befürchten
und nicht zuletzt ist die Deutsche Post
inzwischen einen Global Player im Jahr
2000 gingen sie an die Börse und
übernahm zudem mit einer Milliarden
Transaktion des amerikanische Paket und
expressunternehmen DHL und da kann ich
Ihnen heute ankündigen dass wir ganz
neue Kräfte in unserem Konzern
freisetzen werden kritiker bemängeln
dass die Aufmerksamkeit der Post
zunehmend den Tochterunternehmen im
Ausland gilt die Interessen der
Bevölkerung scheinen in den Hintergrund
zurück wir sind hier 120 km vor Berlin
nicht in der Pampa
Katastrophe aber naja so sind eben doch
eine Million gekriegt was hier draußen
passiert sowieso Kinder inzwischen ist
die Deutsche Post in über 200 Ländern
vertreten und verzeichnete im Jahr 2021
ein Konzernumsatz von 81 Milliarden Euro
allein in ihrer auslandstorte E-Commerce
solutions investierte sie zuletzt nahezu
halb so viel Geld wie in ihr ganzes
deutsches Brief und Paketgeschäft wer
einen Brief verschickt kann sich
eigentlich darauf verlassen dass er am
nächsten Tag oder spätestens am
übernächsten Werktag auch ankommt dazu
ist die Post sogar gesetzlich
verpflichtet doch wenn das nicht klappt
hat das auch keine Folgen der
Handlungsspielraum der Bundesnetzagentur
ist begrenzt sie kann die Post bei
gravierenden Mängeln lediglich ermahnen
und wünscht sich deshalb künftig
Sanktionsmöglichkeit meine Meinung ist
dass das eher noch schlechter wird die
ampelregierung plant daher eine Änderung
am Postgesetz die der Bundes Agentur
eine strengere Marktaufsicht der
möglichen soll die Post dagegen erhofft
sich von der Gesetzesreform eher eine
Lockerung der rechtlichen Zeitvorgaben
für die Briefzustellung denn für die
Post würde das mehr Zeit und weniger
Kosten bedeuten für die Kunden aber noch
längere Wartezeiten wie zufrieden sind
Sie mit dem Service der Post welche
Erfahrungen haben sie gemacht schreiben
Sie es mir gerne in die Kommentare
ähnlich wie die Deutsche Post hat auch
die Deutsche Bahn mit Problemen zu
kämpfen wenn Sie wissen wollen woher die
kommen schauen Sie sich gerne unsere
Kontext Folge dazu an und wenn Sie noch
mehr über die Deutsche Post erfahren
wollen empfehle ich Ihnen dieses Video
unserer zdf-kollegin und Kollegen